You okay?
You need a minute?
Cool. Okay.
Listen up people, I know a thing or two about extinction.
And let me tell you, and you'd kind of think this would be obvious.
Going extinct is a bad thing...
...and driving yourselves extinct in 70 million years,...
...that's the most ridiculous thing I've ever heard.
At least we had an asteroid.
What's your excuse?
You're headed for a climate disaster...
...and yet, every year, governments spend hundreds of billions of public funds...
...on fossil fuel subsidies.
Imagine if we had spent hundreds of billions per year subsidizing giant meteors.
That's what you're doing right now.
Think of all the other things you could do with that money.
Around the world, people are living in poverty.
Don't you think helping them would make more sense than, I don't know,...
...paying for the demise of your entire species?
Let me be real for a second.
You've got a huge opportunity right now.
As you rebuild your economies and bounce back from this pandemic,...
...this is humanity's big chance.
So, here's my wild idea.
Don't choose extinction.
Save your species before it's too late.
It's time for you humans to stop making excuses and start making changes.
Thank you.